المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
ما الذي يمكن ان يضيفه وصول دبابات
ابرامز الان الى ساحه الاوكرانيه والى
الاستراتيجيه الاوكرانيه السيد قبل قليل
قال بانها لن تغير شيئا في هذا المشهد
اولا مساءكم طيب انظري
من وجهه نظري ومن وجهه نظر الضيف
الروسي ويمكن ان تحللي من الصادق ومن الذي
يحاول نشر
كما رايت في الصور
كم عدد التي تم تدميرها هل تم تدمير ال
100 في اسابيع هذا كذب واضح اذا ما كان
هناك معدات قد دمرت معدات اجنبيه هذا ما
يقوم
بنشره الطرف الاوكراني ولكننا نتعلم كيف
نستخدم هذه المعدات
والدبابات والمعدات والانظمه الدفاعيه
تعمل بنجاح عالي جدا وبالطبع الهجمات
المضاده التي يتحدث عنها الجميع
هي
عباره عن هجمات تحاول ان تتخطى جميع
المعدات الهندسيه التي بناها العدو اراضي
الغام
ونحن حصلنا على انظمه
وعندما نتقدم الى الامام سوف نقوم بتقديم
هذه المنظومات الى الامام وهذا سوف يحدث
بسرعه عاليه جدا بالتالي سيد
مجديه في مسار هذه العمليات
وستغير في مسار هذه المعارك الان
المعدات الاجنبيه والغربيه اعلى بكثير
وتتفوق على الاسلحه الروسيه وهذا ما
اثبتته جميع
المعدات التي نحصل عليها صحيح اننا نحصل
على اعداد محدوده ولكننا متاكدين اننا سوف
نحصل على كميات اكبر من المعدات المتطوره
التي تتفوق على الاسلحه الروسيه تكثيف
الهجمات الان داخل روسيا ولذيذ يعني تسير
في اتجاهه اوكرانيا ما الذي تريد تحقيقه
بالضبط كياس من وراء تكثيف مثل هذه
الهجمات وبهذه الشده
اريد ان اؤكد هنا ان القرم ليست اراضي
روسيه
ولم يعترف بها من اي جهه رسميه انها اراضي
محتله اوكرانيه مثل افخاذيا
كل هذه المناطق محتله من روسيا والضربات
التي قمنا بها على مركز الاسطول البحري
للبحر الاسود هذا ما قامت به
القوات الخاصه التي خططت لهذه العمليه
ولقد اكدوا
القتل عشرات الضباط زائد
الجنرال التي كان يقوم باوامر اجراميه
تؤدي الى قتل المواطنين الاوكرانيين
بصواريخ الكليبر ما الذي نريده لسنا نحن
منهجنا على روسيا ولسنا نحن من اعلنا
الحرب ولا نحن من نقتل المواطنين اننا
نتحدث معكم الان وهناك
عشرين طائره مسيره من نوع شاهد وجهت الى
الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وفي الساعه في الساعات القادمه
سوف تصل الى كيف وتضرب بعض المواقع اذا
نحن نحصل على اسلحه متطوره نستخدم
نستخدمها لمعاقبه من يقوموا بهذه الجرائم
طيب يعني الاوكرانيون اعلنوا اليوم مقتل
قد عسكريين في الاسطول الروسي الحربي
روسيا حتى هذه الساعه او على الاقل حتى
هذه اللحظات لم تؤكد او تنفي ماذا تقراون
في هذا الغموض من طرفكم
تعلمون ان روسيا لم لم يسبق لها ولن تقوم
بتاكيد اي شيء او انكاره انهم يعملون على
وينفقون على هذا المليارات في العالم حتى
يقنعوا بعض الدول وشعوبها بموقفهم بالطبع
لن يعترفوا باي شيء انظروا الى المصادر
المفتوحه للجميع في التليجرام او غيرها
عندما قام المواطنين في القرن بتصوير هذه
الضربات هم روس
وظهرت عشرات من سيارات الاسعاف التي وجهت
لهذا المكان ثم قالوا انه لم يكن هناك اي
اشخاص
علما انه كان هناك
سفينه ناقله للجنود تابعه للاسطول البحري
لن تعترف بهذه الاعداد من الضحايا فقط سوف
يسجلوهم كمفقودين كما يقوم بهذا عاده في
روسيا انظريما قاموا به
ومع غير التشكيلات العسكريه بالنسبه
لروسيا اهم شيء الكذب والكذب والكذب
ولكنها سوف نطردهم من اراضينا المتحدث
باسم القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه